[Musique]
nous sommes le 23 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission consacrée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département invité aujourd'hui jean
lain la capelle il était à versailles
hier il est en charge de la campagne de
marine le pen pour la prochaine
présidentielle
il reviendra sur les axes principaux du
programme et sur la polémique date des
emplois fictifs qui touche sa formation
françois de mazières député-maire de
versa et dénonce un grand gâchis
culturel dans son dernier ouvrage nous
l'avons rencontré lors de la conférence
de presse de lancement il revient sur
les choix opérés ces dernières années au
niveau national pour la deuxième fois
une perquisition a donc eu lieu ce lundi
au siège du front national à nanterre
dans le cadre de l' enquête sur les
assistants parlementaires au parlement
européen de marine le pen
cette dernière évoque des tentatives de
déstabilisation et sur le terrain ses
lieutenants poursuivent la campagne
rencontre avec jean lain la capelle il
était à versailles hier donc face à la
presse et face aux militants également
gens là la capelle qui ces derniers mois
avaient pour mission de
professionnaliser le parti en vue des
législatives mais également de tourner
la page
jean-marie le pen je suis avec jean lain
la capelle responsable front national de
la campagne de marine le pen
alors jean lain la capelle est ce que
c'est important pour vous d'être ici
aujourd'hui à versailles
bien évidemment nous avons mis en place
une équipe une tournée qui s'appelle
marine 2017 qui a pour objectif en six
semaines d'aller rencontrer les 95
fédérations françaises les yvelines
étant donc une étape parmi ses 95
fédérations et je suis là pour
rencontrer la presse locale et pour bien
évidemment aussi diffusé des messages
positifs à nos équipes militantes qui
sont en ordre de marche
croyez moi dans une spirale de confiance
qui sont sur le terrain quotidiennement
et qui savent que marine le pen leurs
candidates celle du patriotisme sera
bientôt élu président de la république
les îles ils sont selon vous une terre
front national il n'y a
pas de terre front national ou de terre
qui ne soit pas front national je crois
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un territoire qui
est celui du patriotisme
il ya une candidate elle est la seule à
porter le patriotisme et elle a face à
elle un certain nombre de candidats qui
eux sont les cannas du mondialisme et
c'est là dessus que le clivage va se
jouer peu importe les territoires peu
importe d'ailleurs les partis politiques
je crois que ce clivage est dépassé
aujourd'hui c'est le patriotisme qui
s'opposent au mondialisme c'est marine
le pen
face aux autres candidats et je crois
que c'est elle qui gagnera c'est plutôt
des communes rurales qui qui votent
front national dans les yvelines où il
ya également des grandes villes selon
vous qui peuvent voter front national
je crois que l'autre électorat est assez
diversifié vous le savez nous sommes le
premier parti des jeunes
nous sommes le premier parti des
ouvriers nous avons percé dans la
fonction publique nous avons joué
ensemble de 2,2 d'agriculteurs qui ont
également soutiennent anatole marine le
pen nous avons à cet homme aujourd'hui
deux patrons de pme qui soutiennent
également notre candidate
je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous la portons
à personne une fois de plus nous
apporterons à ceux qui se retrouvent et
qu'ils adhèrent au projet
marine le pen qui s'articule autour de
quatre souveraineté qu'elle souhaite
retrouver la souveraineté les chattes
yves la souveraineté territoriale la
souveraineté économique la souveraineté
monétaire
c'est le droit de passage obligatoire si
vous voulez appliquer le programme de
marine le pen si vous voulez retrouver
photo pouvoir décision à votre
indépendance
un mot également sur françois simeoni
qui est le secrétaire des yvelines
est-ce que selon vous c'est un bon
secrétaire est ce qu'ils arrivent à
mobiliser
dans le fond le front national ici les
yvelines écoutez il a succédé à
son prédécesseur et il le fait fort
formidablement bien
moi vous savez j'ai quelques indicateurs
notamment la progression des adhérents
et aujourd'hui je vois qu'il a progressé
de + 15 % dans son vivier d'adhérents
donc c'est plutôt un très bon signe de
bonne santé dans la fédération
et puis je constate surtout c'est que
les équipes militantes sont en place sur
les marchés
tract col bleu distribué des tracts dans
les boîtes aux lettres et c'est ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui à nos militants ils
le font tous au service de marine le pen
les yvelines sont un terrain conquis ou
à conquérir les yvelines sont comme tous
les départements métropolitains ou
d'outre-mer sont des territoires qui ont
une poche et à potentiel de
développement donc nous avons un
électorat acquis c'est une chose mais il
faut continuer à poursuivre l'objectif
étant que nous arrivions à 50% des
suffrages au niveau national et une voix
chaque département à sa contribution
apportée il y aura des meetings qui vont
être organisées dans les yvelines
d'ici le premier tour alors des meetings
nom des réunions publiques comme celle
là par exemple aujourd'hui puisque nous
attendons comme je vous le disais
plusieurs militants tout à l'heure sinon
le grand meeting régional sur la solide
7 avril avec d'autres candidates à paris
au zénith et il rassemblera toute l'île
de france ce sera un meeting magnifique
sera l'avant-dernier meeting
juste avant le premier tour un mot
également sur l'alliance entre françois
bayrou et emmanuel macron qui vient tout
juste de tomber quelques est ce que ça
vous inspire
n'écoutez pas grand chose pas grand
chose mais macro m'inspirait pas à grand
chose
c'est une bulle médiatique c'est un
un peu le candidat des banques le
candidat des finances on le sait le vrp
de rothschild c'est un petit peu comme
ça nous l'avons qualifié béroul rejoint
berne n'a jamais vraiment de conviction
mero va dans le sens du vent donc il va
du modem à craon pensant que le vent est
de son côté
mais nous avons bien vu que dans les
sondages macro est en train de commencer
sa sa chute et sa dégringolade
dernièrement suite aux déclarations
inadmissible et scandaleuse qui l'a
porté sur l'histoire de france il ya
quelques jours en algérie les affaires
qui touchent actuellement le front
national au niveau du parlement européen
est ce que ça peut avoir un impact sur
vous ici dans les yvelines nous mêmes en
france en général n'ont pas d'affaires
pas de contenu un renne congrès une
manipulation des opérations politiques
très fortes qui continue mais mais mais
mais passé c'est la réalité des choses
et les gens s'affairent différence entre
les affaires réel comme celle de fillon
et les affaires
manipuler comme celle du front national
et de la sphère des assistants ou sens
très optimiste ans au discours
est-ce que c'est volontaire ne votent
pas ou est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
une réelle dynamiteur sa g ce fut arrivé
dans ce mouvement il ya déjà de longues
années j'avais plus de 30 ans c'est ma
sixième élection présidentielle j'ai
passé l'âge de faire du cinéma donc
jamais exprimé de manière extrêmement
sincère je crois que marine le pen sera
élu bien herman président de la
république car elle est la seule à
incarner un projet sans aucun concurrent
en france un projet cohérent stab
structure et efficace qui est celui sur
le terrain du patriotisme et donc je
suis bien à mende une dans une dans une
spirale de confiance nous sommes dans un
cercle vertueux et je ressens cela dans
l'ensemble des fédérations françaises
dans le cadre cette grande tournée et
c'est historique
merci jean lang n'a que ben oui merci
beaucoup
propos recueillis par michael l umih
d'euros politique toujours pour
poursuivre cette édition du ace 7 8
invités mais politique culturelle
françois de mazières député maire de
versailles est l'auteur du grand gâchis
culturel aux éditions albin michel et
pour lui sous ce dernier quinquennat la
culture a été sacrifié ses explications
et les a livrés au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch le grand gâchis culturel
c'est donc le nom du nouvel ouvrage
écrit par françois de mazières député
maire de versailles en collaboration
avec olivier le naire françois de
mazières expliquez nous pourquoi déjà
calé la génèse de ce livre pourquoi
l'avoir est écrit de quel constat vous
partez à titre personnel est pris avec
olivier le naire aussi bien écouter
c'est olivier le naire donc un
journaliste de l'express est venu me
voir en me disant on se connaît depuis
longtemps et connaissent confère un
verset en matière culturelle
et trouver comment des élections
présidentielles c'était intéressant que
l'on met au premier plan la culture
parce que ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que dans cette
élection présidentielle qui est même
l'élection principal de notre démocratie
on parle très peu de culture pas même
quasiment pas culture et donc c'est un
livre un peu les loyers en dix ans sans
que ce soit un propos d'ailleurs de
droite ou de gauche olivier le naire dit
clairement clé de gauche
moi je suis un élu de centre droit eh
bien nous pensons qu'il ya vraiment
nécessité de dire au moment des
présidentielles
parlons de culture et pourquoi le grand
cachet culturel ce parce que on vient de
sortir de cinq ans du quinquennat au
long nous malheureusement on a vu que la
culture est passée au second plan ce qui
est un peu paradoxal parce que souvent
la gauche estime que la coûteuse et
plutôt l'apanage de la gauche est en
réalité on a vu que les budgets baisser
façon importante et on n'a pas eu
quelque chose de significatif sur ses
cinq ans alors je suis pas là vraiment
pour faire une critique du quinquennat
qui fini mais je constate et je le
démontre avec ce livre qu'il ya vraiment
eu une rupture important et qu'il faut
donc aujourd'hui la culture reviennent
au premier plan
quel que soit d'ailleurs celui qui sera
m ce qui veut dire que selon vous
aujourd'hui la culture en france et est
clairement en danger ou alors le mot
danger c'est exagéré alors la culture si
oui je pense que la france incarne la
culture et du monde ça c'est un atout
fabuleux qu'on a c'est que vraiment la
france est considérée comme le pays la
culture
et pour un président ça devrait être un
atout ce que je constate aujourd'hui
comme tout le monde qui ceux qui
s'intéressent aux questions culturelles
c'est que la france ne joue plus cette
carte qu'elle a en main s'écarte de la
culture celle cartes voire dire france
mère des arts ont fait et donc l'idée
c'est de dire eh bien
remettons ça au premier plan et c'est
vrai qu'on peut avoir un peu d
inquiétude aujourd'hui parce que l'enjeu
culturel c'est quoi c'est une culture
pour tous
mais qu'ils soient de qualité et on a
toujours ce danger d'avoir soit une
culture au rabais et qui serait soit
disant pour tous soit contrainte ou trop
élitiste et il faut trouver le juste
compromis
c'est à dire on fait une culture de
qualité pour tous est ce que votre
expérience en tant qu'élu local et
notamment au maire de versailles serait
selon vous un exemple à suivre pour pour
la france en général
est ce que il faudrait s'inspirer par
exemple du mois molière vous avez parlé
de ça durant la conférence est ce que
versailles pourrait être un exemple pour
la la culture en france
alors si vous demandez à un créateur
s'il trouve que ce qu'il a fait c'est
pas mal il va vous répondre oui c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant
effectivement il ya une démarche très
volontaire dans le mois molière c'est
d'aller dans tous les quartiers et c'est
d'essayer de faire monter des jeunes
coup je crois beaucoup à l'esprit deux
trous à l'énergie d'une troupe ce qui
nous intéresse c'est à émerger des
nouveaux talents émerger des nouveaux
talents qui ont une exigence culturelle
et qui la partagent notamment avec les
écoles une dernière question très
rapidement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression à droite dans votre famille
politique
peut-être un peu un ovni à
à défendre la culture comme ça on a
tendance à dire et peut-être que c'est
un stéréotype vous allez me dire de dire
que voilà la culture c'est plutôt un
sujet pour la gauche et que la droite a
tendance à saborder la culture est ce
que c'est vrai et du coup ça fait de
vous un ovni ou pas coûté plusieurs
années j'ai présidé la fédération élue à
la culture de france qui est une
génération et des élus de gauche et des
élus de droite bien je vous dire la
question culturelle s'est jamais une
question de gauche ou de droite c'est
une question d'engagement de personnes
et vous avez d'excellentes politique
dans des villes de gauche et d'exemples
politique dans des villes de droite et
des critiques de mauvaise qualité dans
des villes de gauche est également au
malheureusement aussi dans des villes de
droit donc voir la culture c'est quelque
chose d'atypique faut pas traiter ce
sujet comme les autres
il faut être fier d'un héritage qui est
le nôtre
la france est vilain pays de culture la
france réputation internationale en ce
domaine et bien faut l'entretenir et
c'est vrai versailles c'est pas
assimiler ce que j'ai fait qui est à
mettre en avant c'est que versailles
incarne aux yeux du monde la culture
française et donc voit aujourd'hui avec
mon équipe municipale
j'ai une mission j'ai un devoir c'est
d'essayer de faire encore rayonner la
culture à versailles
merci françois de mazières merci
beaucoup c'est la fin du set 8 invités
pour aujourd'hui et pour cette semaine
on se retrouve lundi avec de nouvelles
personnalités qui font l'actualité du
département
[Musique]